[Music]
with the arrival of zack snyder's
justice league
jon jones has finally made his fully
fledged big screen debut
but just who is this iconic dc superhero
and why a fan so excited to see him in
all his alien glory
this is the history of the martian
manhunter
it all started back in november 1955 and
the pages of detective comics
issued 225 the main story in this issue
follows jim gordon
as he wins a contest to be batman for a
day
but that's not really important here in
the back half of the issue
among the zed list heroes and hair gel
commercials there's a story entitled the
strange experiment of dr
erdell this tale introduces professor
mark erdell
world famous scientist and his
remarkable new invention
the robot brain of the century hoping to
use it to probe the cosmos whatever that
means
erdell turns on his machine and jon
jones suddenly appears
it's revealed that jones is an alien
scientist from mars
transported to earth through the power
of erdelle's invention
erdell explains the circumstances of
jones's teleportation
and states that it may take years to
recalibrate the robot brain
to send the visitor home thankfully
jones takes the news like a champ
and uses his shape-shifting abilities to
transform into a human man
the shock of witnessing this incredible
feat proves to be the last straw for
adele however
who promptly dies now trapped on an
unfamiliar world the alien takes in his
surroundings and realizes that earth is
a primitive place compared to mars
and is desperately in need of a lawman
adopting the slightly more low-key
moniker of jon jones
he sets off on an expository mission
hoping to show earth citizens what he's
made of
jones subsequently walks into the
middleton police precinct and
immediately lands a job
despite straight up freaking out
whenever people light cigarettes in
front of him
this is because in his alien form his
one weakness is fire
which only sounds dumb if you put aside
the fact that batman's weaknesses are
everything including fire and that the
green lantern jarling girl was at
separate times vulnerable to wood and
the color yellow
it's a superhero thing over the next few
years the manhunter from mars continues
to work for the middleton constabulary
in the guise of jon jones ace detective
and as tended to happen in those days
his list of abilities got longer
seemingly with every issue
in his second appearance he exhibits
telekinesis or
martian mind over mata as he calls it
x-ray vision was then added to the
roster
as was the power to scare sharks away by
turning green
all the while jones waits for martian
technology to reach the point where it
can finally bring him home
in 1959 during the earlier years of the
silver age of comics the martian
manhunter made the leap from secret
detective
to full-blown superhero the following
year he became a founding member of the
original justice league of america
in the pages of the brave and the bold
issue 28 in this groundbreaking issue
dc comics united the members of the
justice league batman
superman wonder woman the flash and
aquaman
as well as the martian manhunter green
lantern and an honorary member named
snappercar
who's pretty good at snapping when
martian manhunter does battle against
the martian artifact known as the idol
head of diabolu
everything gets turned on its head
realizing that he can't continue
masquerading part-time as a human
detective if he is to crush this enemy
for good
jones does away with his jon jones alias
soon after he adopts the name
marco xavier in order to infiltrate the
crime cartel
called vulture before disbanding it in
april 1968's house of mystery
issue 173 things remain relatively tame
for the martian manhunter after that
with maybe the most remarkable thing
that happens being his adoption of a
goofy pet sidekick
named zuk sadly he also began appearing
in the comics less and less
after superman was given a promotion to
active full-time jla member
the martian manhunter takes part in one
last justice league mission in a march
1968 comic
and then 10 issues later leaves earth to
lead new mars
martian manhunter isn't seen very much
after he goes to new mars in the early
1970s
bouncing between that planet and earth
on only a few occasions
at one point his fellow jl ayers
superman and batman
lend a hand in a fight on new mars
proving the bond between justice league
members
knows no interplanetary bounce then in
1984 the martian manhunter rejoined the
justice league of america
coming back to earth on a permanent
basis and self-stylizing as jon jones
once more
the late 1980s saw dc scrubbing up its
comics in hopes of achieving greater
mainstream success
as part of this effort the justice
league of america was given a sleeker
and more recognizable name in 1987. this
new run highlighted the martian
manhunter's inherent comedic presence
amongst the other members of the justice
league and padded out his backstory a
little too a year later the character
got his own comic mini series
simply titled martian manhunter and that
one really had some fun with the
characters past
several big reveals come into play
during this run for one it turns out
that dr erdael didn't actually die when
jon jones
shape-shifted and that the character's
alien look is a fabrication
a blend of what martians really look
like and what humans look like
in reality the martian manhunter more
closely resembles a gangly dinosaur
additionally it's revealed that martian
manhunter had been transported to earth
not just through space travel but also
through time travel
it turns out that his people had
actually died off thousands of years
prior to that first detective comic
story
giving him the chance to play with that
classic last of my kind sci-fi trope
the martian manhunter's stories became
pretty tough to follow in the 90s with
each story purging retcon being swiftly
followed by a litany of narrative cheat
days
generally jones still fights a good
fight alongside his justice league
fellows
both as himself and through means of
outside intimidation
as the necromancer bloodwind with whom
he was accidentally merged after that
doomsday knocks him around a bit lou
beetle finds out the truth of the
situation
and then the merged characters both get
successfully separated
later the martian manhunter becomes
wrapped up in the murder mystery
investigation
at the heart of 1992's american secrets
mini-series
five years later he helps found a new
justice league and fights off
invasions of white martians the
malevolent cohabitants of his home
planet
he even becomes trapped for a time in
the phantom zone it's framed by his
meddling brother mala furak
and uses his severed hand to regenerate
his whole body after it's blown apart in
an explosion
perhaps most surprisingly however the
comics also revealed that jon jones the
martian manhunter's first assumed
identity
was a real man who was tragically
murdered so yeah things got pretty weird
but none of it could prepare fans for
the character's live-action debut
1997 saw the premiere of justice league
of america
a bizarre pop culture experiment
seemingly drawn from a dozen different
time periods
its characters came from classic dc
comics its mockumentary film style was a
decade ahead of its time
and its so-called jokes seemed like they
were pulled from a futuristic
post-apocalyptic wasteland
where laughter died a long long time ago
here fans got their first live-action
taste of martian manhunter
played by mash's own david ogden styus
he's portrayed as the leader of the
justice league
and is seen exhibiting powers ranging
from shape-shifting to
well that's it it wasn't a great movie
you know haven't you felt like you
appreciate more of the things that we
have
for us here in this in our world and you
know he's green from there though the
martian manhunter train started to build
up steam
the character debuted in smallville
during the show's sixth season
albeit in human form thanks to the
limitations of tv special effects at the
time
david harewood would take up the baton
and the arrowverse playing jones and
supergirl
the flash and the crisis on infinite
earth's crossover
meanwhile in the world of animation the
martian manhunter has made more
appearances
than you can count with over a dozen
actors lending their voices to the role
over the last few decades it should be
clear by now that jones is a much adored
and vital part of the dc universe
both as a fascinating solo character and
as a founding member of one of the
world's best known superhero teams
so why did it take so long to get a big
screen version of martian manhunter
well he did once come close to getting a
silver screen debut
back in 2007 mad max and happy feed
director george miller was all set to
bring
his vision of the justice league to
theaters the story of what really
happened to justice league mortal is an
absolute roller coaster filled with
studio intrigue
failed dreams and hollywood politics and
among at all miller had tagged his
frequent collaborator
hugh keys burn to play the world's first
major motion picture version
of martian manhunter then in 2013 zack
snyder's man of steel
introduced audiences to a military
officer by the name of general
calvin swanwick played by harry lennox
general swanwick sir
i'm on with the control tower colonel
hardy's on his way in and he's got
superman in tow
superman the alien sir that that's what
they're calling him superman
fan theories quickly circulated that
lennox was secretly martian manhunter in
disguise
and snyder took a shine to the idea
planning a big reveal during the events
of his justice league movie
while the theatrical cut of the film
wound up manhunter 3 however
the character finally made his first
bona fide hollywood debut in the recap
movies closing scenes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one